how true is that that if u.s goes down
the rest of the world is going to feel
it oh that's absolutely true how could
it be any other way what you have to
realize you say that from australia but
a lot of people in america don't see it
that way you know a lot of people in
america say well you know we keep saying
america's greatest country in the world
how do you know america is not the
greatest country that's becoming a
movement in america
by the woke and some of the professors
yeah and it's just you're sitting here
like what is the matter with you but
from your perspective somebody that's
from australia somebody that got to the
highest level of politics in australia
how do you view u.s on what u.s if u.s
falls how the world's going to feel it
like what would happen say u.s falls
tomorrow who takes advantage of people
next well it could be very ugly indeed
you've got what might be called an arc
of autocracy as a pr former prime
minister australia labelled it so you've
got china you've got russia you've got
iran you've got north korea in
particular
and then you've got isis and so forth
and they loathe the idea of western
freedom
is western freedom worth standing up for
we'll ask the people who are so keen to
get to america
they're everywhere the people who want
to get into australia the people who are
trying to get into europe and britain
why do they want to do it because
they're lands of opportunity they're
lands where you don't feel that the
police are going to knock on your door
at 3 o'clock in the morning and drag you
away on trumped-up
charges and take you to a uyghur
prisoner a concentration camp
these things really
matter
and of course what's happened is
that whilst we've been so comfortable
after the second world war in our
western concerts i mean they've been
good years i'm a mid baby boomer boy did
i pick my parents well i lived in
australia it was a free country a land
of opportunity oh just too young to miss
vietnam i've had none of that so while
i've been feeling fat and lazy and
comfortable i hope i haven't been too
bad but you know what i mean
you've had people who loathe the western
way of life not just externally but
within our own cultures
they know the march of the left through
the institutions the cultural marxism or
neo-marxism i don't see why we should
shy away from using that term because
they don't
saying well why isn't why aren't the
working classes rising up we need more
rushes they're not doing it it must be
the strength of the institutions in the
west the families the political systems
the
community involvement the churches the
courts
so let's undermine their validity
and you see it today in the de-staturing
movement the de-statuting movement when
you stop and think about it looks like
an attack on the sins of the past
it's much more than that the way it
plays out in our kids minds is exactly
as it's meant to you're the inheritors
of such a nightmares culture as frank
for rudy from england puts it that it's
not worth defending
and maybe those guys have cities who
want to bring it down are right
and that would be my plea we need to
wake up to this what we've got it's not
perfect
but this is the best way to resolve our
differences and when we need to change
let's do it through the political system
where we can manage our disagreements
which is what worries me so much about
your president's recent speech and the
former prison's response to it
so
so you you're concerned also about the
formers respond to it so please unpack
that
um first go with biden and go to trump
i've been in politics i know the game
okay and in your case it's a slightly
different australia because we have
compulsory voting but i reckon
can i be blunt
i don't want to insult your country or
your country people but what it looked
like to me let me put it that way and
someone can push back if i'm wrong if
i'm being insulting was it your prison
was pole backing
touched the lines that he thought might
bring his voter base out
but in so doing he really took a slash
at all those people who've already been
described as irredeemables and as uh
deplorable
now hang on that's that's tens of
millions of americans
they're not all irredeemable uh and uh
deplorable people
a lot of them are the people we just
talked about covered who who grew the
food
and who took it to market and who
processed it and brought it to your food
your door risking their own health they
were the muscle if you like that kept
the place going that we forget about
the commander-in-chief's job should be
to be a unifier to reach out to lead to
say if you're dissatisfied with our
system if you're unhappy with it sit
down and talk to me and explain why
and we'll try and understand our common
humanity
so we can pull together again and
rebuild a coherent society that's why it
worried me so much
and then of course it invites an
incredible response insane what have you
so
what message does this send to our kids
about the way that you relate to one
another when you've got a difference
what does it say about what real
leadership is
you know henry ford ii
from this country the carmaking family
once gave additional definition of
leadership you know you've got to have a
vision
one you've got to be able to explain it
to others so they know what the vision
is to thirdly you've got to have about
yourself the personal qualities to make
them want to work with you to make that
vision real
i reckon that's a pretty good definition
well what is the vision
and you know and how are you explaining
it and is it inspiring people to work
with you to achieve it or is it an
inspiring division and loathing of
anyone you disagree with well who's the
last guy here that unified anyways
who's the last president that was a
unifier that brought both parties
together that's probably a better
question for americans i admire many of
you i mean you think of a truman david
mcculloch wrote the most when i get a
lot of young people who come to me and
they say i'm interested in politics and
most of them i say forget it because
you're about yourself
i don't use that blunt language but the
really outstanding ones i say go and
read one of the books i always recommend
is david mccullough's book on truman
great big thick tone he was a guy he
left with office with the lowest
approval ratings of any
president-leading office that we know of
we look back on it now and know that he
was one of the great presidents of all
times
i think the thing with approval ratings
is it's also what's happening in that
moment meaning
after 9 11 george w bush's approval
ratings were sky high
i mean to get to 50 at this point in
america i don't know i was in australia
is an anomaly 50
i don't know if trump ever hit 50. i
don't think biden's ever hit 50 much
less 51 i think george w bush at one
point was in the high 70s
um unfortunately that was on the heels
of 911.
um but i mean i've been saying that
for two years now i would love for
somebody to be at the executive office
who can get 60 in this country i've been
saying that
for a few years now i just don't know
who that is but that means adam you've
got to drag people over from the other
side correct you've got you need to
convert hey you're a leader you're not
slamming me because i have a different
view you're not slamming me because i
voted for trump because i felt shut out
correct
you're actually reaching out and you're
saying hey
can we have a conversation see in
australia i don't know what's happened
here but
uh one of our better universities been
tracking confidence in the political
system and democracy now since 1970.
a staggeringly low number of australians
have confidence that our democracy is
working properly if you don't trust at
the system
in fact if you it's bad enough not to
trust the people in it at any given
point in time if you no longer trust the
institutions that's really serious
if you don't even believe in understand
and trust the principles behind the
institutions of freedom then you really
are in trouble so trust is critically
important you don't build trust by
calling people names so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
[Music]